more people are turning to local thrift
stores to come at the rising cost of
goods that according to one research
study the second-hand market is
projected to double in the next five
years to become a 77 billion dollar
industry but could it also see increased
prices as a result of inflation we
looked into it for you
inflation hasn't been a factor for us
and the reason why brian stewart for
goodwill of southern nevada says is
because the major cost of operation for
the company involves staffing and
occupation of space long-term leases can
be foreseen when it comes to staffing
goodwill like many other companies faces
challenges with hiring and retention
some of that is due to what we call good
turnover
goodwill welcomes people who are getting
their start in the workforce
need immediate work
or need a second chance the company
prides itself on employing people with
major barriers like minimal work skills
no high school diploma physical or
mental disability with 16 retail
operations a clearance section for
attended donation stores and an online
store it employs about 800 individuals
stewart says the company is maintaining
operations efficiently as to not pass
along price increases to its customers
right now over the last 12 months
we actually haven't increased our prices
for our core items which are the
clothing on our racks he did confirm the
last price hike at goodwill for clothing
occurred in 2019 an increase of about 10
percent obviously we're you know running
an operation and there are going to be
increases over time um but as you can
see compared to what we're all dealing
with uh in terms of inflationary
pressures
overall that's quite
revenues collected from the sale of
donated goods fuel goodwill's workforce
development programs